[Musique]
allez aujourd'hui quel bonheur de voir
mon jean luc lemoine oh qu'il est beau
celui ci avait que se pose ici j'ai eu
peur j'ai eu l'impression que c'est une
chose nouvelle n'ont rien d'une houle
avait rien d'ouvert en fait on vieux
tout est fermé vous avez bien raison les
incite pas s'il te plaît allez une
question bonjour je m'appelle daniel je
voulais savoir si dans l'équipe
j'étais juge les collègues ou vraiment
des amis car j'ai l'impression que dans
les chroniqueurs il ya quand même pas
mal de petit bâtard
allez on pose les vraies questions 1
c'est une fausse impression cher daniel
il n'y a pas de petit bâtard il ya
quelques gros mais pas et puis quand au
second il assure il veille à l'unité de
l'équipe et qui nous a émus lors de la
1000ème en disant un mot gentil à chaque
chroniqueur si françois n'était pas là
mais j'ai regardé ça j'ai le plus
émouvant c'est celui qu'il a dit valérie
bénaïm fort et valérie dois dire un truc
moi chérie et bien un truc moi si je
t'aime je n'étais plus jamais de télé
sans toi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je m'adresse gênant
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai et je vous ferai une révélation
vous le dit vendredi ou lundi
puisque ça va bouger pour vous tous a
enfin un ménage mais je vous dirai tout
dire on est en train de travailler sur
quelque chose avec la chaîne et je vous
dirai préparation s'annonce quoi par un
pot de départ où c'est pas la peine non
non non c'est pas du déplore déjà les
voir très bon père noël descend par leur
âge et des programmes non en trois
départs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien en tout cas le même sort le sort de
la 1000ème pour mettre une bonne
ambiance cyril avait eu la bonne idée de
demander à chaque qui pour lui était le
chroniqueur emblématique de tpm p ouais
y avait rien à gagner à part une
médaille en chocolat mais on va pas se
mentir tout le monde espérait de cité
enfin surtout un d'après vous tout à
l'heure mathieu me fais dessine pour que
je choisisse
je pars dire nature parce que c'est mon
ami mais honnêtement moi je dirige
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on voit que c'est bien mathieu style
latex sont de 86,7 médias nous a aussi
permis de revoir des images du passé et
constater à quel point nous avions bien
évoluer physiquement alors toi tu es
beaucoup mieux j'aime pas me mettre en
avant
1 mais bon pour une fois mais
franchement il est qui fait la direction
artistique de l'édition
[Musique]
d'accord il est beaucoup plus beau
battant et oui bah oui je parlais loin
c'est ça non mais avant tu es tu es
moche non mais maintenant il est correct
non droit et oblige et c'est une merde
non mais c'est vrai a maintenant tout
est correct
avant tu es toujours été bon vous au nom
veut non non non non je reconnais tu es
toujours été con n'ont même pas parler
de moi mais ça lui est arrivé vers man 3
et vous avez toujours eu beaucoup
d'humilité
non mais non mais vous voyez matthieu
delormeau arrivée dans les couloirs
j'étais avec benjamin rapide
on l'a vu arriver il a le sac à dos il a
les lunettes de soleil n'est pas la
personne c'est tom cruise et des comme
ça et il parle à personne dans les
couloirs sans déconner benjamin n'était
pas fou ah si c'était incroyable
il était au téléphone lunettes étaient
déjà que j'ai déjà concentré quand
j'arrive j'ai les lunettes j'ai
l'émission dans la tête un peu comme un
sportif je refais déjà la descente
et voilà les saucisses pour apparemment
vous avez accroché une porte pas l'air
convaincu pendant logique il a dit
comment semer un peu vexés les chances
mathieu c'est vrai je peux pas lutter
lui d'année en année il bouge pas à part
peut-être les cheveux et élégance
maintenant
[Musique]
choqués ils furent de fursac c'est bon
vous l'avez pas c'est bon alors attiré
des poils mois merci wiki un mec bourré
là bas avec doit aller ce qui fait aussi
la force de tpm pc bien sûr la liberté
de parole qui règne avant l'émission et
dont se sert isabelle morini-bosc ont
toujours nous raconter de belles
histoires bien utile pour endormir les
enfants comme ici la fabuleuse histoire
de l'hermaphrodite de bani oui j'ai
rencontré à manille dans un salon de
massage au sheraton dernier étage un
vrai hermaphrodite dommage nous jure
c'est impressionnant c'est à dire que le
mec il a vraiment une très belle
poitrine et pas du tout transformer et
il avait aussi le paquet comme tu dis et
enfin s'arrêta fonctionnement je veux
signaler
il a pas eu de répit les démons
mériterait sa peinture non mahfoudi
table
[Applaudissements]
deschamps
là bas je vous le redis notre très belle
et vous le savez oui surtout de doux nom
accor à la deschamps oui vous avez des
pubs les plus belles jambes que je
connais ouais vous connaissez vous
suggérer des semaines comme ça vraiment
à l'adhésion de manière grave au final
j'ai la jambe et les fesses aussi un
méchoui 1 à l'exercer alors une question
revient souvent
peut-on tout dire à l'antenne oui fil
des mots ou des expressions interdit
dans tpm paix oui quand même
évidemment évidemment cyril est très
rigoureux là dessus il veut pas qu'on
fasse n'importe quoi donc vous comprenez
bien ce qui est acceptable ou pas je
suis parti de la techno d'isabelle sur
la macro dit vous allez voir c'est très
révélateur
alors quand elle sait quel point un bide
la toile va nous dire ah ils avaient une
top lubrifiantes trois barrages ans elle
est truffée après c'est quoi j'ai pu
échanger j essaie souligné toi
oui j'ai mangé des que les ai mangés
tout peut se soustraire aux calmants ont
vu que ça va
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même cette nouvelle séquence
est très fort ça passe pas on est comme
un problème familial
la semaine dernière nous recevions
laurent baffie dans l'émission et
jean-michel était très content car il
avait enfin trouvé un adversaire à sa
hauteur
vous allez voir comment en une vanne il
l'a mis à la badoit c'est un enfer parce
que ça me fout le petit bonhomme en
mousse dans la tête pendant quinze jours
à chaque fois je le vois je déteste
quand il chante dt je sais que tu adores
mais c'est donc tu vas pas dans le slip
on m'a dit
[Applaudissements]
c'est en tout cas j'aime la côte avec la
banda se passe bien le mec de rien mais
surtout vous avez vu que la trouver une
vanne est là répète plusieurs fois
tellement il est contre lui c'est donc
bien un sniper
ah oui nous l'expliquent modestement en
coulisses depuis des semaines mais un
sniper très particulier
[Musique]
c'est comment parler d'un sujet grave on
avait beaucoup d'humour de courtes
distances on a parfois la larme à l'oeil
mais on rit beaucoup on se surprend à
rire en disant mais comment je peux rien
à ce moment là bas voilà j'aurai
remercier quelqu'un d'autre je voudrais
remercier celle qui est une de mes
préférées
elle le sait ça fait des années que je
reconnais c'est vraiment ma grande soeur
je l'aimais énormément c'est bien sûr
isabelle morini bosc
franchement pour moi a fait partie des
chroniqueurs qui ne partiront jamais de
tpm paix parce que je vous aime fort et
que vous êtes indispensables à
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a mis feu
36 les yeux
c'est ya pas une bonne vanne noms et par
contre ils vivent et meurent est ce que
vous trouvez drôle parfois mais plus
souvent on dort l'antenne
ouais bon du plateau bien jean michel
qui avait aussi beaucoup donné de la
1000ème vous vous rappelez était parti
danser sur la scène du palais des sports
à une plus grand bonheur d'isabelle qui
aime les belles choses car je ne sais
pas si elle vous l'a dit mais elle a une
formation de portraitiste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Musique]
helou fait la plus de poitrine que moi
d'être magnifique mais je suis content
quand je mets des avis et ça me motive
pour les fans du sport après j'ai
commencé comme j'ai offert redynamiser
un petit punk maya paillat passeport et
orthophoniste un 2 sur la côte est quoi
attention il est mieux vu alain votre
mari alain winants quatre fois plus
musclée pardon alors à oui il a une
vraie sangle abdominale a des cuisses et
marathonienne paraître des fesses de
marathonien il a cédé aux abois
redoutable ça va s'arrêter là alors là
c'est d'ailleurs je vous avais proposé
le premier top gênante saisi cette
compilation de moments cours est étrange
dont je ne sais pas quoi faire sept
jours même principe très peu de
dialogues pour un maximum de gênes
[Musique]
et aussi un peu chez moi j'ai fait une
chose
[Musique]
vous n'êtes en effet paul les people
mais le ninja warriors au début ça doit
mettre à l'honneur des inconnus oui
c'est ça c'est toujours chouette de voir
un people essayer de parcours mimie
mathy elles passent pas le premier
obstacle son
ban
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-luc c'est l'arrivée de catherine
laborde dans votre équipe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous mettrez je me reconcentre
tout de suite pour les machos j'aurais
pu l'être et nora dans cette compilation
dans fait non car elle n'aurait mérité
des séquences à part il faut le
reconnaît le pitbull breton a beaucoup
changé cette année
on connaissait la femme de caractère la
grande gueule et ben ça suffit la
caricature et nous rase et bien d'autres
choses
la preuve avec cette semaine en images
au pays
comme dans tout le pays
ces deux visites exclusives à commander
là ça va
[Applaudissements]
on s'amuse on pleure on lui qu'à toi
il ya des méchants et des gentils
[Applaudissements]
et pour sortir les moments difficiles et
j'avais pas y avoir des amis c'est très
utile
[Applaudissements]
non
madame c
rien
[Applaudissements]
et va bien elle va bien elle sera de
retour de barre alors là c'est aux gens
ce mea culpa maintenant je me suis
souvent moqué des défauts amitié de
mathieu avec les stars très bien il y en
a des vrais talents rares depuis des
semaines il faisait croire qu'il était
très ami est très proche de maître gims
oui c'est se moquer eh ben on avait tort
a enfin eu tort il est battu
[Applaudissements]
mais pour moi
[Musique]
bello
une fois
tu t'appelles
il n'y a pas de suite mais on dit tirer
la couverture piquée celle des enjeux
des petits trucs perso comme ça
d'étudiants faut faire aller en tout cas
ça fait une belle transition vous passez
à tout ce que vous n'êtes pas voulu voir
mon émission et on commence par le
nouveau jeu d'actu de touche pas à mon
poste vous savez les photos principe est
simple nous montre des photos on doit
deviner quelles infos médias ça se
rapporte grande réussite
info suivante regard des flamants roses
stéphane bern conseil que frédéric lopez
à la trappe et stéphane sur une jambe je
vous mets la saison selon me regarde
c'est un doux l'allaitement fausser le
gland ou la pâtisserie c'est un gland à
gauche parce que trouver dans un assaut
on va se retrouver dans un instant avec
legault les cherry et on saura s'il a
demandé à ce que la constitution en
quatre prénoms
et je vous dis on apprend plein de
choses avec jean michel cohen moi je l
adore jean michel est ce que je peux
faire moi pour maigrir j'en vis de mes
gages envie de perdre devenez maigrir
alors si vous nous rejoignez je sais
qu'on a trop détracteurs de tpm paix et
il ya d'autres chroniqueurs qui vous
dérange
auguste qui vous diront oui on a un que
je peux pas encadrer ces deux langues
regardez c'est vrai elle s'est fait
tatouer cauet sur le pied des premières
le singe qui lance son caca à faire du
sa place face aux singes qui a le cul
qui grattent et dans un instant le
challenger sera la biche qui pète
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît ne salissez paca primes
non je fais très bien
[Applaudissements]
bon ça me suis là c'est ça les amuse
gueules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]